il fut un temps où notre royaume était
parfait puis une malédiction déferla sur
notre monde
l'empereur il détruisit notre planète et
fait disparaître la famille royale
l'univers est sur le point demain de
retenir mais un jour un héros allait
rétablir la justice
waouh heureusement tu as de bons
réflexes
ça fait 13 ans que je ne connais nous
endort le monde est quand même plus
grandes salles
tu n'es pas censé être couché
je suis plus un corresponsant
plus sûr que oui bonhomme ce qu'il faut
c'est que tu lui prouve que tu es prêt à
les trois grands axes me suis fait une
foulure du corps entier
ja du gauche a change du syndic rendu
compte seulement deux secousses d'âge de
naissance ces leçons de la famille
royale
ce qui veut dire votre excellence 7e
mourir
il est grand temps de sortir ses
poubelles nauséabondes quels sont tes
projets kraken détruire une nouvelle
planète et voir les peuples du cosmos
sous m avec terrasse vous n'avez pas
creux ce serait pas mal ouais ok qu'est
ce qui conduit faut qu'on réfléchisse un
plan vous pouvez le descendre on est
moins nombreux
bien moins hard et peut très bien m'en
sortir dans les salles
c'est sûr que ça change un peu la donne
survivant de banat gens que nous a pris
notre planète mais tous ensemble on va
la récupérer les stocks frtp d'abord oui
j'attends ce moment depuis 13 ans sacré
seul à pouvoir le faire je m'en sors mal
sous pression je n'ai plus rien